institute
i'm very happy to have these two
programs running this semester on
causality and
learning and games welcome to the boot
camp for the learning and games program
it looks like a
very exciting
week that we've we've got planned uh i
should start by saying a big thank you
to the organizers for the for the boot
camp uh also the program organizers so
vazila signus uh costa stuskalakas dylan
foster mike jordan christos papa
demetrio and eva tardis so big thank you
to those folks
so
you know these boot camps i think are
really important for the programs
getting getting everybody on the same
page technically
they also have a huge archival value in
you know giving a snapshot of the state
of the art uh with all these amazing uh
tutorial lectures so
it'll be a great week um uh just a few
uh logistics sorts of things uh you know
we all have to wear masks um please
don't bring food or
or or drinks in from outside um you've
got all of those for the breaks you've
seen before the the lectures in the
morning and during the morning and
afternoon breaks for lunch you're on
your own if you'd like to drop um
you know
backpacks and things off
there are lockers on the far side of the
building on this level they work with a
pin code so you're welcome to use those
hopefully you've found the
wi-fi cal visitor or eduroam
[Music]
our videographer amid far in the booth
here is going to be
you know helping out with with
connecting speakers computers and
microphones and so on everything's being
live streamed and we're on
we're on zoom here
um
also uh a big thank you to kelani
pendland
at the back here who did all the local
arrangements for the boot camp
thanks kalani
all right i'll hand over to vasilis to
tell us about the themes of the workshop
yeah thank you all for joining either in
present or virtually um uh so yeah so
the bootcamp is supposed to be
some fundamental topics that will be
very useful for the three workshops for
example that we've organized as part of
the semester the one is on uh
adversarial approaches to machine
learning and costas is talk and maybe
george's talk would uh will be giving
some phenomenal
you know
an overview of fundamental topics that
will help in that direction the other is
on learning and strategic behavior and
nika eva and uh and myself will be
giving some tutorials on topics related
to that and then the final workshop will
be on multi-agent reinforcement learning
and so on friday we'll have a day of
reinforcement learning in the morning
dylan we'll talk about reinforcement
learning
mostly from the theoretical point of
view and in the afternoon qi jin will be
speaking virtually on multi-agent
reinforcement learning so thank you all
for all the speakers for agreeing to
give these tutorials which is a
significant amount of work
and uh thanks cassie for presenting
today and so i'll hand it to you and
thank you very much
uh thank you very much vasily
thank you peter
it's great to see everybody here
i'm excited to be uh in berkeley for the
for these two programs there are
intimate connections between the two
uh programs so i'm excited to be part of
both
uh and uh
yeah thanks for coming to this tutorial
so um
i didn't choose the topic for the
tutorial vasilys did so thanks vasilis
for this web
uh you know for putting the weight on my
shoulders and this
very broad topic so
i decided to change it into an even
broader topic
all right um
but yes since this is the first tutorial
i thought i would talk
about various
uh
questions
on equilibrium computation and its
interaction
with machine learning
so um
you know let me start with those
pictures that uh
people in the mail
show
to
brag about the recent accomplishments in
machine learning
from image recognition and speech
recognition to protein folding and
uh atari games and translation and and
and text generation
so uh
at the optimization uh
heart
of these breakthroughs
broadly speaking
what lies is a minimization problem
of course you know minimization is uh
optimization is important and
optimization has found this recent uh
a lot of recent applications important
applications in machine learning
uh so um
uh what is different uh
in in those you know recent machine
learning accomplishments is that
the optimization problems that arise
deal with high dimensional very high
dimensional variables
the functions on the evolved are not
convex they're typically non-convex
and they're essentially only accessible
through uh
lower order
uh you know information like asking
the function value or the gradient
function value on the positive side
these functions are you know almost
everywhere
differentiable
uh and smooth and they're lip suits
so um and uh you know for all these
reasons for the you know the the fact
that they're non-convex and they're only
accessible through lower or their
information typically the way you
approach these optimization problems
uh is via a simple method like gradient
descent
and the good news is that in practice uh
you know even the even though those
problems are non-convex
so
we know theoretically we have
established theoretically various works
do that you know gradient descent
reliably gets to local minima of these
those functions and
the empirical finding is that this local
minima do a pretty good job for the
applications that we're interested in
it's not a guarantee but that's an
empirical finding for all the
applications that are mentioned in the
previous slide
so okay so the starting point of uh this
talk and the you know
this semester maybe and you know its
interaction with the other program
is that uh
we have been witnessing
a dawn of multi-agent learning
applications
um
in uh machine learning
uh
and uh
uh there's a difference between these
applications here that you see like uh
uh you know alphago and libratus the the
algorithm that beats humans in poker
starcraft
uh you know soccer between robots uh
adversarial learning and gans okay so
there's a difference on the optimization
from the optimization perspective and
that is that uh
uh i mean you know those problems are
not minimization problems anymore but
they're equilibrium computation problems
so in the equilibrium computation
problem an agent is not learning
by themselves in some environment
that is stationary
but
they are learning and making decisions
in an environment that is changing
and the reason the environment might be
changing maybe various
it could be changing because there are
other agents that are
that have conflicting or aligned
interests and they're also learning and
making decisions at the same time
there may be adversaries
or noise or distribution shifts that
poison the data corrupt the data or
change the data from when learning
happens to when the algorithm has been
used
and uh you know
you know
the problem maybe game theoretic
implicitly because you know like the the
other agent representing constraints you
want to enforce like this was happening
in gans and
and other applications uh recent
applications in the now so
the game might be explicit okay so game
theory is a
important and old field and has found
many applications
in various in various disciplines so
the game could be explicitly modeling a
game a market
road network
data network a
ecological or biological system an
energy grid interacting robot sensors
and so on so forth
you know you know a game maybe
if you want
be a good model for the brain
and you know like
then you know like a learning and so on
so forth
uh or the game could be implicit so uh
uh the other agents may be representing
constraints that you want to enforce uh
on the primary you know on the objects
you're trying to optimize
a game could be
modeling the fact that you are
optimizing in a distributed way
um again could be capturing the fact
that you want your uh the the thing
you're learning to be robust to changing
conditions
uh and that's related to adversarial uh
uh learning
uh there are uh uh you know learning uh
arises uh sorry uh games arise very
naturally
in causal inference applications and
that's an interesting point of contact
to the other program
uh and uh
you know games have you know as i was
saying earlier have been used to model
the brain
to to to to to to just to study the
cultural evolution of language and so on
so forth so
uh so so games could be explicit or
implicit and we're interested in all
these applications
uh as you know so let me you know close
this you know general slide with
a dictum that uh
minimizations to canada well what
equilibrium learning is for future
amounts yeah so i think that you
mentioned a nice point about like
here
because of causal influence could you
elaborate on that and give some examples
yeah so uh
yeah so for example basilis has done uh
work on that so oftentimes uh
uh
you know like uh
doing causal inference from
observational data requires you to use
instrumental variables or other uh tools
and oftentimes this ca this come in as
uh
you know like the constraints you want
to enforce
look like conditional expectation
constraints
and uh
to enforce those types of constraints
it's very natural to turn them into a
a min max optimization problem so so
yeah and uh i hope at some point during
the semester you know we're gonna listen
to vasilis or you know like one of the
seminars
and you know dive into that more but
that's an important application i hope
in fact
the next the next uh
workshop for this program will be
devoted to mid marks optimization i hope
we will have some talks about that there
yeah
yeah that's a great question a beautiful
connection between the two programs
uh in any event uh you know coming back
to the thread of my uh
uh tutorial today
uh there are issues okay so i was saying
earlier that uh
in non-convex optimization gradient
descent works in the sense of finding a
local optima that in practice are
performed reasonably for the
applications we're interested in
so uh
on the multi-agent front
these methods are not as good okay so
our practical experience is that uh
if you endow each of these
agents with the ability to run
a simple method like great and descend
what you find in practice is cycling
behavior
or even chaotic
behavior
methods typically have a very hard time
converging
let alone to something
meaningful and uh
you know parts of the goal of this
tutorial is to understand how deep
this problem uh is
all right
okay so and uh sort of like you know uh
to motivate kind of like a little more
uh be a bit more concrete about where
this uh you know non-convexities and
sounds of sort of arise oh is there a
question yeah oh yeah
yeah
hi yeah uh just about the cycling
behavior that you mentioned
uh
don't these
dynamical systems often cycle around the
equilibrium
or cycle in a way that
the average that averages to the
equilibrium
yeah so that's a that's a
very common uh i will i will talk about
this a lot so
that is very common when the game is
well behaved
uh in a sense that i will discuss if the
game is not well behaved uh you you know
all bets are off
uh but we'll get to that in a in a
little bit
uh so to to motivate that you know
cycling and you know sillatory and
chaotic behavior uh let me talk about
specific uh applications uh you know
which is not a explicit game it is an
implicit game it's a it's a game that we
construct because
by looking at equilibrium this game
allows us to access
something interesting
so
what gans do
is they try to generate objects
that are
interesting and high-dimensional
so um
so so like
the photos that you see here which are
which are not
photos of real humans but these are
photos of
humans that were hallucinated by a deep
neural network
so that deep neural network
takes as he put boring randomness
gaussian isotropic noise
passes it through
non-linearities and several layers of
linear and non-linear operations and
outputs an object that
is interesting
okay so that is at least the goal
the goal is to turn boring randomness
and low dimensional randomness into high
dimensional interesting randomness
by passing the boring randomness through
a a an interesting function
now
how do you access how do you find how do
you identify how do you set the
parameters of a neural network to do
this job
so the adversarial so the gan
approach
is to set up a two-player zero sum game
between a player who is tuning the
parameters of this neural network
and another player
who's tuning the parameters of a
different neural network that is called
the discriminator
so the the architecture is like you see
in this uh picture
so the
there's a player controlling the
parameters of a generator
and a player controlling the parameters
of a discriminator network both are deep
neural networks
so the player
controlling the parameters of the
generator wants to tune them so that
boring samples become interesting
samples
at least in the eyes of the
discriminator so the discriminator's job
is to take us input
either photos
generated by the generator or photos
generated
photos from the real world and
distinguish them
so the discriminator is uh
rewarded for uh discriminating between
fake samples and real samples from the
target distribution
the generator is rewarded for fooling
the discriminator
and there you know various uh utilities
you can write for the generator and the
discriminator here's one
which is used in what are called faster
steam gans
so
you give the discriminator and the
generator opposite utility so you set up
a zero sum game
so the loss function for the
generator
which is the same as the
utility of the
discriminator is how well the
discriminator distinguishes
between real samples and fake symbols so
you compare the expected output of the
discriminator when you plug in
a real photo
and you compare that against the
expected output of the discriminator
if you plug in a sample
generated by the generator so namely
sample boring randomness pass it through
the generator and then pass that through
the discriminate
so if the discriminator is doing a good
job these two expectations should be far
uh if the generator is doing a good job
this expectation should be close
this is objective function is you know
you know if the discriminator was rich
enough this is trying to capture the
vassar steam distance between i mean if
you optimize this
trying to capture the vastus in distance
between the two distributions and you
set up a zero-sum game uh uh you know
hoping that uh
if you compute the equilibria of this uh
zero sum game you will arrive at a
generator that is fooling the
discriminator thereby
doing a a good generation
uh question
it seems like you don't actually want to
compute an equilibrium here because the
equilibrium is pretty easy you just
say uh thumbs down thumbs up on all the
images that are in the
database and thumbs down otherwise so i
can i can give you
a equilibrium to this game but it's not
interesting
um
like
sure but i guess okay like
you know
okay so uh i guess it depends on what
you plug in here for this expectation
right and whether this expectation
converges to the
to the to the you know if you if that
expectation com you know like if you if
the empirical converges to the target
right
so like ideally what you want is that
this doesn't have ridiculously large
complexity
so that
the empirical expectation is a good
approximation to the true expectation
so that what you just described isn't
actually a good you know equilibrium for
the game
so yeah if you you know if this guy can
memorize all the photos in the database
uh you are correct but
you want to set this up so that uh
this doesn't have enough complexity to
do that
and for this reason
uh
this expectation which is over the real
distribution is well approximated by the
empirical distribution over the database
doesn't make sense so so notice that
here i've written the expected over all
real images of all humans that could
possibly like
this is a distribution it's an idealized
uh
uh uh you know generating process
that biology gives us
making humans and creating humans
uh and uh this is uh
not biological this is
but
what the generator generates right and
uh
um
yeah so this is my objective function
now
in practice i'm going to approximate
this by the empirical average and
this one as well and i hope that the two
are close to each other otherwise
what you just said is a valid complaint
but i guess i was wondering if it's more
the
some stochastic gradient center some
algorithm is
it's important what algorithm you're
using to find it because it's the it's
the uh trajectory towards it that's
actually more interesting than the
equilibrium itself so
so all the issues around generalization
of the plural networks are relevant here
for for this to actually work uh because
typically this is actually going to have
a you know large complexity and
it's going to be hard like like unless
unless you use ideas like
what you're alluding to you won't be
able to argue that you generalize well
and you know like the truth of the
matter is i
i have i i know i do not know of any gun
except trivial cases
that comes together with a certificate
that they really did a good job okay all
of it is practical so
uh so that's a great question
uh to think about during the semester
maybe but but yeah
your complaints are all valid and you
will have to do something
along these lines to
uh you know save yourself from these
issues but yeah
but i'm not here today i'm not here to
defend guns i find it an interesting
idea
i know no gun with a certificate that it
learned the target distribution yes so
so there's something technical i don't
understand about the definition of
utility
yeah if if the discriminator
um
perfectly identifies uh the synthetic
images as real and the real images as
synthetic
you would get a negative value there
but in fact the generator is doing a
very poor job right
so the generator is penalized if the
discrepancy is big
uh you're you're not looking at
discrepancy right because there's no
absolute value there
oh you mean oh uh i i mean if
discriminator is actually reversing
but okay but if we get there the
screamer is going to put the minus sign
and you know reverse that so that's not
a
big issue
at equilibrium this is not going to
happen okay because the discriminant is
going to put a negative sign and reverse
that
effect so that's not a big deal
um
okay
uh
the point is i'm not here again to
defend guards but the point is this is
an interesting game
the variables x and y are high
dimensional the utility functions are
very non-convex very non-concave
and the question is
you know you know what is game theory
you know
going to say about these types of games
all right
uh so the first problem is these games
may not have equilibrium it's very easy
to construct games
with non-convex uh concave utility
functions that have no equilibria
so you know what what do we even
recommend
to compute in this scenario
what is the meaningful solution concept
this is you know one of the one of the
things i want to discuss
without
a lot of clarity about what the target
is
practitioners
have tried to run gradient descent to
solve these problems
so what did they do
because these things are high
dimensional and really only accessible
through
first order information
they have the two players of the game
the generator and the discriminator
run gradient descent in parallel
so the the the generator is g you know
trying to optimize
their utility function the generator is
optimizing their utility function
because the two utilities are negatives
of each other you get this so-called
gradient descent ascent dynamics
all right
now people in practice don't literally
run this dynamic that bells and whistles
to that dynamic
but
you know roughly speaking they have the
minimizing player and the maximizing
player do
first order methods in parallel
and here's some stuff that happens okay
so in this example
the target distribution is handwritten
digits from the amnes data set
and what these panels show is what
distribution the generator is generating
if you were to stop the dynamics after
10k steps 20k steps 50k steps and so on
so forth
so what you see here is that along the
training process the generator is
generating garbage symbols
and settles on a
uniform you know like a you know
a distribution over a single garbage uh
symbol okay
in the bottom example the target
distribution is a mixture of gaussians
a range whose means are arranged on a
cycle
and what you see here is another
prototypical behavior of you know
gun training dynamics which is to
shift from mode to mode of the
distribution so so the generator and the
discriminator are chasing each other
so the generator is you know going
around the cycle generating from
different modes of the mixture
so these are just examples of what goes
around in training guns
but but but the issues uh
arise even for like for trivial
distributions and here's one example
uh so imagine that the target
distribution is a really trivial one so
it goes here like in two dimensions
uh you know i put them in at three and
four that's not important for the
example isotropic gaussian in two
dimensions
and
let's try some very simple generator a
linear generator it takes its input and
adds the input to the parameters
two dimensional parameters so you take
the input the z you know the the z from
you know
normal zero one is your identity you add
to that x
the discriminator just projects
so that's my gun architecture
so if i were to write down the vassar
scene objective which is to
compare to to look at how good a
discrimination job
the discriminator does
so i have to compare the expectation are
the true data of the output of the
discriminator versus the the output of
the discriminator on the fake data what
is the fake data
you take gaussian samples pass them to
the generator plug them into the
discriminator
you know what comes out of this is this
very nice objective function which is a
bilinear objective function
in the parameters of the discriminator
in the generator
it's a nice function because it's going
you know
linear in both the variables
and
this game has a very obvious equilibrium
which is
for the generator to choose as x this
vector
and the generator to choose as y the
zero vector
if they do not do that
if they do not do as i described the
other player can punish them infinitely
much okay so like
if x does not choose this as as a
their vector
the y player can't punish them
infinitely much
and similarly if this guy doesn't choose
the zero as its vector
the other player can punish them
infinitely it's a trivial game
but here's what gradient descent does
again i'm coming to your comment in the
question in
a little bit so what do you see so here
you see the two parameters uh you know
y1 and y2
maintained by the discriminator they are
oscillating
and their average is zero which is the
target which is the true you know the
right thing
but they're oscillating around
here the two parameters of the
discriminator so so they're also
oscillating and their averages are good
so three and four respectively
but you get these oscillations which are
very typical
uh in the case where the game is well
behaved so you
oscillate around the equilibrium
so so in a paper with vasilis and andre
elias
and and
zhang what we did is we
uh tried
you know various types of things that
people do in practice to
you know improve the training dynamics
and guns like uh
you know
using momentum
uh
uh having the
you know one of the two players uh
running smaller speed so uh you know one
step of one versus several steps or the
other
and you know
across the board you see oscillations
this is very hard to remove
[Music]
uh in fact
oscillations arise uh you know maybe
this is the most trivial example of
oscillations
it's a very similar game to the previous
one it's just a single dimensional
uh the equilibrium is zero zero
uh and and here's what gradient descent
has sent dynamics to they just
pictorially you know as was
mentioned earlier
uh they are
you know cycling and actually spiraling
around and away from the equilibrium
so you can easily verify that you know
this this picture because
the gradient descent ascend dynamics
look as this if you square both sides
and add them up you'll see that the norm
of the
of the iterate increases as time
progresses
all right so so to just wrap up
so trading these training oscillations
and garage solutions arise even in two
agent zero sum games
even when both players know exactly the
utility so they don't need to learn them
while optimizing them just they know
them exactly even if it's low
dimensional
so uh you know
motivating the question of you know what
what's going to happen if
you add all the complexities that you
you know have
in
in general machine learning applications
so this is sort of like the topic of
this discussion let's dive into more
technical stuff
so the broad focus of this tutorial is
going to be on multiplayer games
you'll have a lot of agents
each with a constraint set
and each coming with their own
function that they want to minimize so
it's a multi-objective optimization
problem
or equivalently each with their own
objective they want to maximize so i'm
going to be having
i might be talking about losses or
utilities so these are negative of each
other
right so game theory is like talking
about utilities
machine learning is like talking about
losses so i'm going to maintain both
notations for maximal confusion
so
in this type of
setting
you have tension right
and the tension you may have is that
it's possible that the
you know
choices that other people make
influence what actions are available to
you so
uh there's also tension because
uh each person's utility function or
loss function depends on
not just their own choices but also
the choices made by the other people
uh and and and you know this utility
functions may be misaligned
uh
and and players may be uncoordinated in
in trying to
optimize those uh loss functions
uh so so game theory offers solution
concepts proposals for what might happen
or is reasonable to happen in this kind
of scenario
and the question
for this tutorial is
uh
what happens uh
uh well if you have these agents run
very simple algorithms
the main question of this tutorial is
when agent use online agents use online
graded descent or some other
simple
learning dynamics
will the joined
behavior of the system converge to in
some sense to nash equilibrium
correlated equilibrium or some other
reasonable
solution concept
now
from an optimization standpoint and game
theoretic standpoint i mean all
standpoints i guess
it's really important to uh whether
the utility functions are concave
in uh
[Music]
you know their own actions
uh equivalently
uh whether the loss functions are convex
in a player's own act own actions
if this is the case this is called a
concave game
if this is not a case this is going to
be called a non-concave game
so
the um
terminology concave comes from the fact
that typically game theory you refer you
talk about utilities right you want
utilities you maximize your utility you
want to be facing a concave function
you're optimizing
right so typically in game theory
models postulate concave utilities or
quasi concave utilities
but as i was mentioning earlier with the
example of guns you you might you may
encounter very commonly non-concave
utilities so
uh uh and you know that's part of the
uh of the discussion here so now
so in non-concave utilities uh
even equilibrium existence is at risk so
in general there are no
uh equilibria uh
that you find in in you know like
typically like like there's a non-nash
libra corollary and so forth
but even in concave games you have
computational issues with some of this
equilibria so you might be interested in
equilibria that are tractable
all right so the important you know
distinction is concave versus
non-concave games
in concave games there are issues of
tractability with some solution concepts
and we want to understand
the behavior of
tractable solution concepts such as
correlate equilibrium and minimizing
regret
on the non-concave front
it's not even clear what we should be
targeting
and and in this tutorial i want to talk
about all these questions
so let me be a bit uh more precise so
another focus uh
uh is gonna be zero-sum games
uh
and the zero-sum games i'm gonna be
talking about
are games where you know you have two
agents one is paying the other so
l is a loss for this guy and a gain for
that guy
so this guy's gonna wants to minimize
the loss this guy wants to maximize the
loss and there are some constraints that
tie the actions of the two players
in general the only assumption i'm going
to be making on l is that it slips it's
smooth so it's good it's gradient is
lipsets and that the constraint that
couples the actions of the agents is
convex and compact but i'm not going to
necessarily make simply simpler
assumptions unless i statement
i will focus on simultaneous games in
this tutorial
however sequential games are also very
important to study and i will touch upon
them a little bit uh if i have time
there is particular a lot of work
including people from people in the
audience on
the sequential version of the problem
where one of the two agents is
committing on a decision first
and letting the other player respond
when talking about zero sum games i uh
regardless of whether it's simultaneous
or sequential i will abuse notation and
uh for compactness represent it as min
max
it will be clear from context whether
this min max is a simultaneous with max
or sequential max
and similarly i may be talking about
mean maximization or max minimization
uh referring to both problems the
simultaneous and the sequential
again
the context uh will uh elucidate what
i'm talking about
now
when you're thinking about zero-sum
games
the
uh
uh it's illustrative to compare the
situation to the uh single optim single
agent optimization problem
we're just minimizing a loss one agent
in the world minimizing a loss by
themselves
and uh
uh to to make this comparison it's uh
interesting to consider two settings the
the let's say the classical setting and
the deep learning setting
yeah
is there a question there is a question
from the virtual engineer environment
does that mean for nash equilibrium to
be intractable
what does it mean for nash equilibrium
to be intractable that it means that
in that context it meant ppd complete
so it is uh
you know it is it is complete for a
particular complexity class
uh that class is not the np class which
is more common a common in uh
you know when writing interactability
theorems
uh it is a class of problems that
contains other
perceived heart problems such as finding
brighter fixed points and and so you
know spurner
zlemma and other and other problems in
topology
so in that context
nash equilibrium being intractable meant
that it is as hard as any other problem
in that class in particular
as hard as finding fixed points of or
approximate fixed points of lipstick
functions
uh and uh
i will touch up on this uh uh in my
third in my in part three of my on in my
tutorial a little bit more
so in that event so making this
comparison which is illustrative
uh
it's important to distinguish the
classical setting and the uh and the you
know modern deep learning side so in the
classical setting
what you want when facing a minimization
problem is that your
loss function is convex
in the in the min max setting what you
want is that your
loss function is convex with respect to
the minimizer player's variable
and concave with respect to the
maximizing players variable
uh
if you have this you have also
phenomena's min max theorem which states
that
if your constraint set is a product
constraint set then you can swap the
order of min and max so in particular
simultaneous and sequential doesn't
matter in that setting
uh from an optimization standpoint
uh also the the problems are
essentially
equivalent
uh so we know of many methods uh to
solve them in fact i hope that in this
you know in my next lecture i'm going to
show you
uh one of these theorems
but long story short there are many
first order methods
that find approximate minima for
minimization problems and approximate
min max equilibria
for for these types of problems in a
number of steps and queries to the
loss function and its gradient
that are polynomial in the desired
approximation
the
smoothness of the ellipses of the
gradient and the
some notion of diameter of the
constraint set
and by
approximate local minima what i mean is
0.6 star that cannot be
changed to decrease the function by more
than epsilon similarly
over here i mean
as epsilon approximate equilibria i mean
points x star by star such that
changing x cannot decrease the function
by more than epsilon changing y cannot
increase the function by more than
actually
so if you're you know if you're
interested in these types of approximate
uh
global solutions
uh you you can attain them in a number
of steps that is polynomial in the
underlying parameters so the two
problems are
not very different in their classical
setting
coming back to this picture
now
where we got the gradient descent a
first order method oscillating around
the equilibrium
uh the conclusion is that
the training oscillations you see here
are not an artifact they're not
reflecting any underlying interest
ability in this problem but they are an
artifact of the method that we're
running here grading descent ascent
so one of the questions i want to ask in
the uh later today
and the next lecture is
is it possible to change the method to
modify it so that you don't see these
oscillations this this looping behavior
that's right yeah so yeah exactly so as
i mentioned earlier
uh this you know starting here the
equilibrium is here and i'm oscillating
around and away from the equilibrium
that's an important drop yeah that's
because we started discussion about the
inner and outer oscillations someone
could say why i cannot
backward run the
the problem in order to have the
oscillation inside
correct that would give
yeah so i'll talk about that and that's
motivation for some of the methods that
i'm gonna discuss
but yeah so at this you know at this
thing or level of generality one of the
questions
is this can we change the method somehow
to remove those oscillations
the other question i'm going to ask uh
gives us a moment
actually please ask your question so
because i'm going to change i'm going to
i'm going to go somewhere else yeah what
is the key difference between the
classical and the modern setting i'll
get to that in uh
yeah
yeah but uh speaking is you have no
convexity that's uh
so here we have a
nice function we're trying to minimize
right the almost function
and here we have a function that is
convex in the minimizer variables
and the minimizing
minimizer players variables
and concave
in the maximizer right so for any choice
of x the maximizing flip players is
facing a nice concave function
for every choice of y the minimizing
player is facing a nice convex function
so you're trying to find a saddle like a
global subtle point
uh and you know as a as as you know
these two boxes illustrate you know
they're not
you know like
you know this is not more challenging
than that one and in many senses they
are equivalent
yeah for this example is the key
difficulty because the function is not
strongly concave and strongly
that is correct so if this were strongly
convex and strongly concave you wouldn't
have this issue
okay good that's a great one so
second question i want to ask is
different one
uh and that's more uh
uh
motivated from uh from a purely
optimization standpoint
so uh what is the fastest possible rate
at which you know these types of
learning dynamics can
uh converge uh to uh can identify the
equilibrium whether they're siliter or
not that's the second question i want to
ask next in in the next part of my
uh tutorial okay so
for concave games which we're going to
look at in the next part of the tutorial
we're interested in two questions can we
remove the oscillations
second question is what is the best rate
at which we can compute
equilibria in these games so these are
the two questions that we're going to be
talking about in the next part
deep learning setting is when you drop
convexity here and convex concavity here
so you just assume
lipstickness and smoothness of your
utility
and um
you know as i was saying earlier i'm
going to focus on the simultaneous case
and def definitely is different now from
the
uh sequential case
one little comment only under product
constraints
this is easier than that or better said
this is not harder sorry this is not
harder than this okay
looking at the strategic starting uh
what you have on the right that looks to
me like a sequential game where correct
the way i have it you know not to go
back to the comment i made earlier that
i'm going to be abusing mutation
and writing this in a compact form
uh whether i mean single time is for
sequential
so this is a better picture we have two
agents one is playing the other they
have to choose simultaneously
of using notation i'm going to write it
like this
whether you know whether these median
marks are in parallel or
depends on the context and we'll mostly
be focusing on simultaneously okay yeah
can you
know about what do you mean with the
phrase under product constraints
is not easier
you know so what i mean is that uh
uh
if you can solve this
then but
it's a little bit out of context but if
you can solve this that is a solution to
that
not the other way around so the solution
sets are nested
um
all right so with non-convexity
as we know
minimization problems are a bit hard
these are empty heart affordiori in fact
uh in the simultaneous case
they may not even be equilibrium so so
even equilibrium existence is
problematic
if this game is simultaneous yeah if
it's sequential it's not a problem but
if it's simultaneous
it is a problem
but uh
you know the approach uh in the middle
is to just target non local equilibria
in this uh
case so you know let's let's study local
equilibria
so what could be uh
local equilibria well here's a
definition
uh i'm gonna be calling x star
an epsilon delta equilibrium if
changing x star in a ball a delta ball
around it intersect the constraints
cannot decrease the function by more
than epsilon
same over here so an epsilon delta local
mean max
is a point x star by star so that
i cannot change x
in a ball
uh intersect the constraints
to decrease the function more on epsilon
and
you know symmetrically for the y player
and uh you know another way to an
equivalent way to view these
two solution concepts that i have on the
board here
is that they're
equivalent to i mean if delta if the
radius in which you're looking for
deviations is small enough compared to
epsilon and the smoothness
these are actually equivalent to fixed
points
of the gradient descent map
on this side
and the gradient descent ascent map
for this side
okay so you can view them in
two ways
uh either with these two definitions
or if that's better for you
think of these as fixed points of the
gradient descent map
and these are fixed points of the
gradient descent ascent map okay these
are equivalent as long as
you're not too greedy about your delta
like your delta is small enough compared
to the target epsilon and the smoothness
all right so what do we know about these
problems well on the left hand side i
mentioned that earlier and uh here's a
formal uh theorem
uh
if you're not too greedy about the delta
about the radius in which you're trying
to find the v you you have you know you
think about deviating
uh then first order methods uh
find the epsilon delta local minima in a
number of steps and queries to the
functions that are polynomial in the
approximation and the smoothness so no
problem there
if you are too greedy
you change the problem from a local one
to a global one and it's empty hard
all right so of course you cannot be too
greedy because
you turn your problem into a global
optimization problem but if you're not
too greedy first-order methods work
on the right-hand side
because of this equivalence to fixed
points of the green descent ascent map
you can also argue that these things
exist if you're not too greedy
if you are too greedy they don't exist
but if you're not too greedy they do
exist
and for this reason it's a reasonable
target for optimization methods
yeah because they do exist at least okay
if you're too greedy that don't even
exist so you know good luck uh you know
checking for them but
um
all right so the question here is okay
so they do exist but what's the
complexity of them
so the questions i'm gonna ask in the
third part of my tutorial is
uh
questions around you know along this
line so
uh so so so for in the in the deep
learning setting
uh training oscillations could be
reflecting computational attractability
so what i want to investigate is do you
know is there underlying interactability
even when you switch to local notions
right so
over here you know once you switch the
local notions of
local solution concept there is no
interruptibility
so the question i want to ask here is
is it the same thing is it
you know do you remove interactability
on this side as well or is there still
interactability even though you're
looking for local
solution concepts if there's still
intractability
here even if you look at local concepts
then you know
that could explain the issues people
face when training guns that's that
could be an explanation of why
they have hard time uh
optimizing guns versus you know solving
this other you know like language models
and so forth
that's the question i'm going to ask in
the third part of my tutorial
and lastly in the in the fourth part of
my tutorial
i'm going to ask the following question
if there is interactability
what are tractable game classes what are
tractable solution concepts what would
be a computationally
uh tractable uh framework to develop
for these you know non-concave games
okay so what is the
you know so so game theory has spent
most of the past 100 years since the
paper of borrel
[Music]
thinking about concave games
with a lot of success in various
disciplines so i guess the question is
you know what what should they do in the
next hundred years hopefully this
semester and this program at simons will
carve out some paths for what gaming
theory should do in the next hundred
years
when facing non-convex non-concave
utility functions or non-convex loss
functions
so to summarize the goals of this
tutorial
i'm going to be thinking about games
such as
you know
you know mostly simultaneous games
involving multiple agents with you know
different utility functions
and
the question will be if they run some
simple method will they get to some
meaningful solution concepts
and i'm gonna as i was saying earlier
i'm gonna distinguish concave games and
non-complete games uh and uh
uh
ask the questions that you see
summarized on the board
on the non-concave side which is the
topic of the next uh today
i'm gonna ask
is there a way so sorry again these are
tractable games but uh so uh uh you know
i'm gonna ask the question first
can we remove the oscillations that we
experience uh in these games
that learning uh for you know like that
learning dynamics experience in these
types of games
and
well you know what the optimal rates of
convergence are to equilibrium in these
games so these are the two questions
this is about removing oscillations this
is about just plainly what's the fastest
way to get to equilibrium
on
the non-concave game side
tomorrow first hour i'm gonna
be looking at the complexity of finding
local
solution concepts in non-concave games
uh
long story short it's gonna be
intractable
okay uh okay so you know
and um but you know i'm gonna show you
how to prove injectability
uh and uh
you know uh
since even the local solution concepts
are intractable
the question is what becomes of deep
learning in that setting
right so
if you know if gradient design is not
going to be working for us anymore
in the multi-agent uh
learning setting
you know what should we do
all right and i'm going to be talking
about
classes of games where there is hope
as well as solution concepts that are
tractable and you know bypass maybe
sidestep some of these interrupt
abilities
so uh these are uh
uh yeah so this is this this is a
summary you wanna talk about and maybe
there are three minutes uh for questions
um the first question about the
okay i will
have the chance to discuss them more in
detail for each question but for example
even if they are interruptable uh
simplex in one sense in theory it seems
to be a very bad
method right
but in practice we love it sure uh
it could be the same case that for
example the smooth complexity the smoke
given that we have not defined that kind
of stuff like what is the smooth ppa the
behavior
do we have any idea about this kind of
yeah yeah so first of all from a complex
standpoint smooth people i mean there
are recent papers for smooth games and
in fact uh
there was a paper last year that you
know if you take a normal form game and
you
perturb it with noise that's still
people to complete so that's not gonna
be
uh an avenue for you so but an avenue
for you would be to characterize game
classes
where uh you can hope that equilibria
are tractable
which is you know
the motivation for this uh question
definitely
uh you know uh tractability results are
often worst case and the one i'm going
to be talking about is worst case
so which uh you know motivates several
avenues for research
but um the importance of interactability
results is that they remove the
confidence that you have that you know
you can just run great in descent and
get somewhere and you know let's see if
that is good practically but no there's
no confidence
so either you um
bill you cannot build a computational
framework without any confidence that
running your basic tool which is great
in descent
will get you somewhere
all right before you inspect if that is
actually interesting
yeah
i know a couple of the colleagues
watching this online are
optimization theorists who've worked on
equilibria for their whole career right
so they're going to want to ask before
the computer scientists got interested
in all this we had say extra gradient
method right and it provably did some of
these things so i know you'll probably
talk about extra gradient but very
quickly because you sort of say
what did extravagant not do the you know
that you're aiming to do that's right
yeah so we'll talk about extra graded
and related methods for when i talk
about concave games so extra great does
not resolve the issues over here but
it uh does uh
remove oscillations and in fact i'm
going to show a classical proof from the
80s but not for extra grading but a
related method
that shows you how to at least
asymptotically
have last literal convergence to
equilibrium so i will i hope you know
i hope that i will be able to present
the proof
uh
and uh and yeah and then i'm gonna ask
some questions around that okay but
uh you know
long story short rates are not
understood
uh for lasting their convergence
rates are well understood for the
average rate of convergence of these
methods
but last iterate rates are not
understood
yeah
so uh
just to understand
uh
something about the third question
uh
when
the game is computationally
uh you say that you see training
oscillations
uh does that mean that they cycle around
the point that is not an equilibrium or
or that they don't converge to anything
even ergotically
so oscillations is a bad term here okay
so installations is a word being used by
people you know training guns but
uh you know as i mentioned earlier
you know i'm referring to potentially
chaotic behavior is i'm not talking
about you know going around the
equilibrium in a cycle so
this the system could be chaotic
and uh it's not well understood what it
does so what i'm saying is let's let's
say that you know
replace training oscillations with with
frustration here could be due to
computational attractability
and
let me ask one last question for this
session from online is there any
evidence like in the single agent case
that in the multi-agent case the local
optima are almost as good as global ones
uh not as far as i know i mean these are
all yeah so these are all wide open
questions i mean the we haven't you know
done you know
so
it's not clear what the you know like i
guess you know what the answer to this
question will reveal is that
you know um
the obvious ways to define local
equilibria give rise to interactability
so definitely these are not good
solution concepts anyways because of
tractability issues
uh so
you know it's unclear if you want to
study them because you know they're
intractable anyways but so
there's no confidence that you know you
you will build a framework that you know
will get there so that you know let's
ask that question then
uh so you know um yeah at this point we
don't even know what you know a
plausible uh tractable target is let
alone whether it's a good one
but from a mathematical let's say
standpoint
uh
for guns say because it depends on the
application
for guns i wouldn't think it's an you
know
necessarily a good solution constant but
like
uh when you think about uh agents
uh i'm gonna talk about that tomorrow a
little bit when you think about agents
who only understand their utility
functions
via first order information about those
utility functions
then these local uh
notions of equilibrium are very
reasonable right because these are
points
where
all agents decide that based on the
information they have which is first
order
they cannot improve okay
so that could be reasonable in that
type of context where you know you know
a lot of agents in a high dimensional
setting
only have access to their utilities
through very simple queries
uh uh you know i i can buy that concept
in that kind of scenario
so let's um
end the session so that we have the
break there's going to be a 30 minute
break
thank you
[Applause]